- [Instructor] Let's talk about magnets
and magnetic forces.
Magnets are these neat
objects that are able
to attract metals like iron.
Magnets are used in all sorts of things,
from holding paper on your refrigerator,
to computers, to compasses.
So magnets can be used
to stick things together,
point us in the right
direction, and even lift things,
and they do this through magnetic forces.
If you've handled two magnets,
you felt magnetic forces,
even when the magnets
weren't touching each other.
That's because magnetic
forces are non-contact forces,
which just means they
can affect other objects
they aren't even touching.
Magnets will attract or repel each other,
and this attraction or
repulsion is a magnetic force.
But magnetic forces don't
affect everything the same way.
Otherwise, a magnet would stick to you,
not just a refrigerator.
In this video, we're going to
talk about the magnetic forces
between two magnets.
So why do magnet sometimes
attract each other
and other times repel each other?
Well, this has to do with the
orientation of the magnets.
Orientation is really just a fancy word
for how the magnets are positioned
compared to one another.
You see, it turns out that
each magnet has a north
and south pole,
but what does this have to do
with attraction or repulsion?
Well, as you may have
heard, opposites attract.
So, if you face the
north pole of one magnet
to the south pole of
another magnet, guess what?
They will be attracted to each other.
But if you turn one of
those magnets around
so that you have two north
poles facing each other,
they will repel.
And the same thing would happen
if it was two south
pulse facing each other.
So the direction of the magnetic
force completely depends
on the orientation of the magnets.
Orientation, though, is just one thing
that affects magnetic forces.
The strength of magnetic forces depends
on a couple of things.
For one, distance.
If you've ever held two magnets,
you may have noticed that
when you move them closer,
they seem to almost jump together.
Or if you try to push
two light poles together,
they get harder and
harder to hold together
the closer you get.
This is because magnetic
forces depend on distance.
The closer the two magnets are together,
the stronger the force between them.
So, as the distance decreases,
the force increases,
but the farther away they are,
the weaker the magnetic force is.
So, distance increases; force decreases.
The other big factor that affects
how strong a magnetic force is...
Well, the magnets themselves.
Sub magnets are really weak,
like a lot of refrigerator magnets.
Others are so strong that even tiny ones
can be almost impossible to pull apart.
Some of these stronger
magnets are even used
to make high-speed trains
levitate off the ground.
And yes, this rectangle
is supposed to be a train.
While my drawing isn't amazing,
the fact that magnetic forces
can levitate a train is.